TODD KERPELMAN: So
in a previous video,
you learned that you can use
GCM to send notifications
through APNs to iOS devices.
But to many developers, APNs
is a bit of a black box.
And come to think
of it, so is GCM.
Put them together and you've
got a black rectangle, I guess.
Well personally, I find
having a little background
on how things work
underneath the hood
can help out a lot
when stuff goes wrong.
So let's shine a light on
half of this big old rectangle
on this episode of "Route 85."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So APNs is a service that sends
notifications to iOS devices,
whether the target app
is in the foreground
or in the background.
So how does it work?
Well for starters, you need two
important configuration bits
to make this happen.
First off-- the device token.
You can basically think
of this as the address
of the device you
want to talk to you,
but one that's
unique for your app.
It's also not really the
address of the device.
You know how when rock
stars check into a hotel,
they use a fake name?
Well, the device token is kind
of like having that fake name.
It lets the hotel manager know
that, hey, it's cool for you
to visit your rock star friend,
because you know the alias
that they're checked in under.
Is that Matt and Kim?
It kind of looks
like them, right?
Yeah.
So when your app gets
permission from your user
to receive notifications, iOS
talks to APNs and requests
a device token-- basically a
fake rock star name-- which
is then given to your app.
Now if you were just building an
iOS app using nothing but APNs,
you'd need to pass this token
back to your server somehow.
We'll get into what GCM
does at a later point.
When your server passes this
device token back to APNs,
it's your way of
both identifying
the device you want to talk
to, as well as proving to APNs
that you're allowed to notify
that device in the first place.
The next bit you need
is the APNs certificate.
This basically
allows your server
to talk to APNs securely.
And hang on, we've got some
massively over-simplified
explanations coming your way.
One common way for two devices
to talk to each other securely
is to use public and
private key encryption.
Alice encrypts messages
using Bob's public key, which
only he can decode on his
side using his private key,
and then vice versa.
So let's imagine your server
is Alice in this scenario.
And if you want to talk
back and forth to APNs,
you're going to need your
own private key and APNs'
public key.
In some cases, like
the openssl tool
that you can run from
the command line,
you pass these two
keys in separately.
But for many third party tools,
including GCM, these two keys
are combined together, along
with some other information,
into a p12 file that we
colloquially refer to
as the APNs certificate.
So with all that
background, let's look
at what happens when we send
off a notification via APNs
using, say, a little
server that you might have.
For starters, we'll
use that certificate
we just talked about, containing
your private key and APNs'
public key, so that you can talk
securely to the APNs service.
Yes, I know APNs
service is redundant.
Shut up.
Now when you send
off a notification,
you're going to need
to include things
like the notification
message, badge count,
or any associated data.
And you're going
to send all of that
along with the device token.
Now when APNs
receives that token,
it's going to do
some verification.
It'll make sure it's a valid
token, it hasn't been revoked,
and that it actually
belongs to your app.
At this point, if
everything looks good,
it will go ahead and
schedule the delivery
of that notification at
some point in the future.
When does it
actually deliver it?
Honestly, that's
kind of up to Apple.
And they're not super explicit
about the logic they use.
There are a lot of different
factors involved though.
But you can influence this
by labeling your messages
as high priority,
which has a priority
value of 10 here, or a normal
priority, with a value of 5.
A high priority message
would be for something
where the user might
get upset if they don't
receive their message on time.
A chat message or
a calendar reminder
is a good example here.
A normal priority message is for
something less time critical.
APNs will often
group these messages
and send them all
at once as a way
to conserve the user's battery.
And they may even get
throttled and not send at all.
But still, it's a good way of
respecting your user's battery.
So if it's not an
urgent notification,
consider sending
it normal priority.
Now, what happens
when your device
receives the notification?
It depends a lot on what's going
on with your app at the time.
If your app is in
the foreground,
iOS will simply hand the
notification off to your app.
It won't show any kind of
display at the system level.
That's completely left up
for your app to deal with.
If your app is in
the background,
iOS will commonly show
a notification-- usually
as a banner up on top here, but
it depends on your settings.
And it will probably be listed
in the Notifications panel
as well.
If the user selects
that notification,
your app will come back
into the foreground.
And at that point,
your app has a chance
to handle the notification.
Now, there is one other
attribute of notifications
you should be aware of.
And that is the
content-available flag.
The purpose of this
flag is to tell iOS
that this would be a
good time for your app
to do a little background work.
For example, you might want
to tell your news app that you
have some breaking
news available,
and your app should go
and download and refresh
the day's top headlines.
Now, these notifications
always need
to be sent as normal priority.
And developers typically send
these as silent notifications.
That is, they're
usually sent without
an associated alert
message or sound,
so the user doesn't notice them.
When iOS gets these kind of
content-available messages,
it will pass the notification
along to your app.
And your app will have
up to 30 seconds--
but it might be a little less,
depending on certain factors--
to do whatever background work
it needs to do, and then let
iOS know that it's finished.
Now, how you actually handle
these notifications or what
methods you use are
all very good topics
that I'm going to
leave to another video.
Honestly, you're troopers for
sticking out with me this far.
So there you go.
That's APNs in an
overly-simplified nutshell.
But wait, this is a video
series on GCM, right?
How does GCM fit in
this whole scenario?
Well, we will take a
look at the second half
of our black rectangle
in a future video.
In the meantime, feel free to
check out our documentation.
And we will see you
soon on "Route 85."
[MUSIC PLAYING]